The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANA BELL: So let's
look at the example,
or the in-class exercise,
with while loops.
Oh good, we got some varying
responses here, perfect.
So the code is, "You're
in the Lost Forest.
Go left or right?"
OK.
So here, the while
loop is checking
if the input is equal to
this particular string.
OK.
And if it is, type
the same thing again
and ask them for more input.
So my question was, what happens
when you type in "R-i-g-h-t?"
And I think the majority of
the class is getting it right.
And maybe the
people who answered
this are maybe changing their
answer to something else,
but you're right.
So you ask the question
again, "Go left or right?"
And that's because
Python, again,
is very, very particular.
We're telling it
that the user input
must match this string exactly.
So "R-i-g-h-t" is going to--
even though it says right,
it doesn't match up.
So if you wanted-- I'll just
show you in this example here--
if you wanted to take
care of that case,
then you'd add this little--
you'd expand on this line right
here, which says, "while n = =
'right' or n = = to "R-i-g-h-t"
or whatever other cases
you'd want to take care of.
OK.